wenn der tank wagen vorfährt beginnt das
hauen und stechen das drängeln schieben
der kampf ums wasser
10.000 liter sind im tank der wird in
etwa 45 minuten leer sein
in dieser hitze steigt der bedarf jeden
tag es reicht einfach nicht immer mehr
wasser wird gebraucht und dann
beschimpfen sie uns und drohen uns
prügel an
natürlich sind die qualität der es kein
wasser gibt
auch so china de wie muss ich behaupten
denn wer zu spät kommt geht leer aus
hey lass mir auch was übrig meine
familie kocht auf was
zweimal täglich kommt der tankwagen
wenn's gut läuft jedenfalls
ich kann einfach nicht mehr jeden tag
das wasser holen ich weiß nicht wie ich
das durchhalten soll
wir sind ja alle am ende wegen der hitze
die slums in delhi wo die armen wohnen
sind nicht ans leitungsnetz
angeschlossen was zu china mühsam nach
hause trägt muss reichen für alle und
alles kochen waschen trinken je heißer
es ist umso mehr wasser braucht die
sechsköpfige familie
wie viel wasser soll ich noch schleppen
meine arme schmerzen jeden tag mehr
meine kinder und mein mann sind bei der
arbeit die können nicht tragen helfen
ich muss das allein schaffen aber ich
habe asthma und diabetes und die hitze
macht mich kaputt
delhi brütet schwitzt leidet 45 46 47
grad das kommt schon mal vor aber zu
dieser jahreszeit sollte es längst nicht
so heiser
das ist aber kein einmaliges phänomen
das ist ein trend und er wird immer
schlimmer wir müssen global etwas gegen
die erderwärmung den klimawandel tun
aber wir müssen auch lokal schnell und
gezielt auf die auswirkungen von solchen
hitzewellen reagieren um damit fertig zu
werden müssen wir uns umstellen und
anpassen
denn die hitze ist eine bedrohung die
ernte ist verkümmert viel früher als
geplant mussten die bauern ihr getreide
reinholen in einem land in dem millionen
menschen ohnehin hungern verschärft dass
die ernährungskrise
auch die stromversorgung ist ein problem
die netze brechen zusammen unter der
last unzähliger kühlgeräte die auf
hochtouren laufen
und natürlich leiden die menschen der
kreislauf macht schlapp hitzschlag droht
nicht nur für alte und kranke sind die
temperaturen lebensgefährlich
eine klimaanlage
ein ventilator ein platz an dem es sich
aushalten lässt die stadt delhi hat 120
hitzeschutz lager aufgebaut für menschen
die sonst kein dach über dem kopf haben
die männer sind nicht faul es ist
einfach zu heiß und sie brauchen eine
pause bevor es an die arbeit geht der
beste platz ist immer der kühlste und
das ist hier der boden
die meisten sind wanderarbeiter die
sonst auf der straße lebt in der hitze
ist das eine qual sie gehen jetzt nur
früh morgens oder am abend arbeiten
ansonsten bleiben sie drinnen sich aus
ravi kommt aus einem kleinen dorf etwa
400 kilometer von delhi entfernt
er hat die weite reise auf sich genommen
um geld zu verdienen
ich habe zwei schwestern drei brüder und
ich bin der älteste 35 jahre aber noch
nicht verheiratet meine familie ist arm
und einer hochzeit kostet geld auch für
die hochzeit meiner schwestern muss ich
zahlen erst sind sie dran dann ich
am nachmittag muss raus wenn er
liegenbleibt verdient er kein geld auch
wenn er aufsteht und sich quält ist es
nicht viel wie unzählige andere ist
fabian gelegenheitsarbeiter der anpackt
wo er gebraucht wird ein wichtiger
faktor im indischen wirtschaftssystem 10
bis 20 rupien also zehn bis zwanzig cent
bekommt rawi wenn er hier mit anschiebt
wenn die sonne direkt auf den kopf
brennt ist es kaum auszuhalten und
schnürt die brust zu mir wird schwindlig
alles verschwimmt vor meinen augen
manchmal klappt ich fast zusammen dann
muss ich mich ausruhen bevor es
weitergeht
die pause ist kurz
durchschnaufen dann kommt der nächste
auftrag
das ist sehr schwer mein herz rast schon
wieder aber ich kann es nicht ändern
das ist sein verkaufsschlager
wie jackpot ist seit 15 jahren in dem
geschäft selten ging es besser als jetzt
es ist unfassbar heiß 46 47 grad die
leute leiden deshalb brauchen sie viel
eis zum kühlen jeder hat durst und ohne
eis kannst du keine getränke kühlen denn
die leute hier sind ja arm einen
kühlschrank können sie sich nicht
leisten
das ist natürlich förderlich für djs
geschäft er ist so eine art mobiler
kühlschrank r satzung beliefert das
ganze viertel ein großhändler stellt ihm
nachts einen riesigen eisblock vor die
tür und früh am morgen dann geht wieder
auf tour
es ist auch in wikis eigenem interesse
möglichst schnell zu liefern denn
logisch geschmolzenes ist unverkäuflich
genauso wie verdorbenes alle sitzen also
im selben boot haben denselben feind die
hitze
wie läuft's bei euch
furchtbar glaube ich dir das fleisch
wird ja schnell schlecht ja wir brauchen
viel eis
15 stunden täglich arbeitet wie arbeitet
auch gegen die zeit
das eis das du bringst schmilzt schnell
was soll ich machen du musst einfach
mehr eis kaufen
ein guter tipp von wie den gewieften
aber irgendwie ja doch schön zu sehen
dass zumindest einige wenige dieser
hitze auch was positives
abgewinnen
[Musik]